I think it's it's especially crucial
this year in part because we have seen
and it's partly thanks to sky which has
been in the vanguard of trying to
mainstream public awareness about the
issues surrounding ocean health and it's
the deterioration of ocean health over
the past decades we've seen public
sector and private sector initiatives
taken with the EU the g7 coming up in
Canada is going to have a special place
special emphasis on this so there is a
momentum I even saw a billboard on the
way into London today amongst all of
those advertising makeups and movies and
all the rest of it here was one
advocating awareness about the
importance of getting plastics out of
the ocean and out of our daily use in
life and so idiot there is a momentum
that has begun to develop it's it's this
ocean day is going to take place and be
able to perhaps accelerate that momentum
to some extent people will say you're
the queen of Jordan you have a coastline
water in a huge country of about 40
kilometres or so they need a tiny coast
so why do you why are you getting
involved in oceans why are you an ocean
angle elder I've been connected to ocean
since my early childhood growing up on
the Pacific Ocean and to today and my
sustainable development work in Jordan
the Middle East and and beyond which is
focused on human security refugees a
conflict recovery and in various regions
including ours and the eradication of
poverty as an ocean elder I'm
emphasizing the connection between human
security and ocean health it's a
connection that's often overlooked and
it's critical that people understand
that our health is a species relies upon
the health of the oceans and that's so
important isn't it given that the vast
majority of the world's population don't
live beside oceans don't see the oceans
well the vast majority of the world
population actually maybe not vast
majority live within sixty two
kilometers of the oceans and billions of
people rely on marine life for their
source of protein hundreds of millions
rely on the oceans for their livelihoods
for their food for their security we
rely on our ocean habitats mangroves
coral reefs and and and other you know
wetlands and and and barrier islands for
our protection from storm surges let's
push on into that that that cause and
effect the crossover the effect on human
populations as we say human populations
who who don't necessarily rely they
think on the oceans in actual fact they
do all of humanity does because of some
of the issues you're talking but also
because every breath we take every drop
of water we drink is connected to ocean
health but what you already talked about
almost gives us cause to despair there
seems to be so much going wrong with the
oceans from the plastics we've talked
about that statistic that they'll sue me
more plastic in the sea than there are
fish particularly with declining fish
stocks then we get things like
acidification sea level rising heating
up of the oceans the list goes on is
there any reason to hope there is I
think hope if everybody can maintain a
commitment the average person to become
more aware of how much plastic is a part
of your daily life and we're seeing
conflict arise that's already occurring
some of the major conflicts that are
occurring in the world are as a result
there are so many conflicts and there
are conflicts that are in the public you
know in in the headlines that are
associated with you know civil war and
and other causes and yet for example in
the Syria conflict the the one of the
driving factors in that conflict which
was the migration of people during a
drought period caused by climate change
to the big cities caused a congestion
and an
intensification of frustration and
hopelessness for those who couldn't find
jobs and and and shelter for their
families and that that was one of the
key factors that led to the uprisings of
now displaced millions of people and are
in a region in two country neighbouring
countries as well as into your own
country my country and in particular but
in Turkey and Lebanon of the effect of
that huge number of particularly Syrian
refugees in Jordan it's something over
six hundred thousand is it not many of
them very young people many of them
living way below the poverty line how
does a country like yours cope with that
well we have always been a a welcoming
and hospitable country to people seeking
refuge from conflict and other causes
for probably the millennia but it's
certain certainly for many many decades
and we do the best that we can the
Syrian conflict is one of a number of
conflicts that have been caused by water
mismanagement and ocean issues such as
Yemen Somalia even in India and Sudan
all of these countries there is a
connection in terms of the large numbers
of people who have been displaced and
conflict occurring and many of them -
the way we look at our natural resource
base and how well we protect it I mean a
problem on this scale is you've touched
on clearly needs global action and we've
got to address this then the United
States the biggest economy in the world
and they pulled out of the Paris climate
change Accord
I mean you disappointed by President
Trump in doing that I think it's
extremely short-sighted and all I can
say to myself and do say to myself
constantly is why not not only the
president but the people around him who
are part of this movement
are they not concerned about their
children and their children and what
kind of a world they will live in
because anyone who's looking at
short-term political gain from taking
such a destructive series of steps
rolling back those kinds of protections
which are in place for their children
and their children and for our species
as a whole is not it's just not thinking
do you think then the message is getting
across and that the actions are
following and will follow will be even
increased Oh Ann don't think we can be
complacent at all but I think
increasingly the message is coming
across increasingly people are aware of
the individual steps that they can take
within their families within their
communities the pressures they can bring
on retailers and and and on the private
sector and I think we're seeing a
growing movement but we need to take
action much more quickly than we are and
that is the message that I hope people
are hearing and willing to take to the
ballot box willing to take up with in
whomever they have you know an impact
influence on and and and just carry the
message forward every one of us can play
a role and that role is really important
last question not concerning the oceans
at all well although I'm sure he's very
interested in the Duke of Cambridge
Prince William is visiting at least
fairly shortly and I believe he's you're
gonna meet him in Jordan as well I I
won't be seeing him in Jordan but I hope
he'll have a very a very fulfilling and
happy and interesting interesting visit
there it is a our region is is in the
throes of what I hope is a very messy
transition to something better
ultimately God willing but it's it will
be a very interesting visit for him no
doubt and and and I there will be many
people welcoming him with with open arms
hospitable culture I know that no doubt
you watch these brothers Prince Harry's
wedding a
couple of weeks ago and back to the
issue of getting the message out it
seems that those two brothers and their
spouses there they're not going to be
perhaps like their the elder Royals in
the United Kingdom they're going to be
like you and they're going to speak out
on the issues
I suspect including this one that they
care about yes I I wouldn't want to take
away from what the older generations
have tried to do and mate and have
succeeded to do and and maybe more quiet
and reserved ways but I think they bring
a lot of hope to a great many people who
are involved in in issues that that are
important to people young people in
particular but really to all generations
ultimately and it was a beautiful
wedding
she's a beautiful bride her mother III
as a mother of children and and and
grandchildren I admired her mother but I
was I wish them both very happy and
fulfilling and productive life together
your Royal Highness well we wish you the
best of luck with your campaigning thank
you very much indeed